foreign
[Music]
what's up Marie
um a whole lot but I'm hoping you can
kind of untangle it let's do it just
drop the big ball of yarn here right on
the desk let's untangle so I have two
big issues
hopefully you can help me with that
um how do I get my partner to grow up
so a little background uh my my first
issue is this my wife
no all right go ahead first issue
first issue is he is in his 30s and
season
um well we have been together since
about 2018 so that long
gross you kiss your son
I know I know
here's the thing okay okay so he all
these years like especially um we have a
kid together we had um we had our son in
2019 while I was pregnant I kept telling
him
I really need you to get your driver's
license because I can't be the only
parent taking him to daycare to doctor's
appointments and he said yeah yeah I'll
get up I'll go ahead I'll do it and he's
been saying oh yeah I'll get my driver's
license
all these years and I just you know and
then have you ever played Texas Hold'em
no okay it's like a it's a poker game
yeah and uh
at some point somebody says I call
and what that means is like everybody
has to show their cards to see who wins
and every time you make these demands
he's like I call
and you do nothing
yeah I know you stoled him like his
mommy and then you'll make out and then
he's like his life just goes back the
way it was
ta-daway I know why in the world and I'm
I'm saying this seriously I have a smile
on my face
why would he get a driver's license
you do everything
I know you have sex with him like
there's no reason for him to do anything
yeah he doesn't have a job either does
he no he does have a job oh he does okay
yeah that brings me to a third issue but
I wasn't going to discuss that yeah
let's do it all
all right so uh the second issue is one
of the issues actually wasn't the issue
that I did bring it up in my email
um I didn't read I didn't see your email
so just I know no I was just I'm just
trying to remember my email to help me
be on track
um but the other issue is
we have you know we have a four-year-old
and you know he is he has extra needs
um he is severely autistic like
non-verbal
um very sensory seeking he has a lot
and my partner Works an overnight job he
has to get a new job
yeah I tried I've tried talking about
this but like it won't work with my he
has a second job um coaching Jujitsu
yeah that's gotta stop listen
everything's gonna stop
I know
I don't know how to fix it
okay
um before I start talking and I hate
going into these Waters because these
waters are uncomfortable okay and I've
been laughing having fun with you and
all that but I know this is very serious
okay
yeah
before I get into the hard part of this
call
um
do you still like him
I do like it's okay if you don't it's
okay
no I do like him I enjoy our
conversations and whenever I think of
leaving I just think oh my gosh I'm
gonna hurt him so bad because he's not a
bad guy okay that's you are sacrificing
yourself on the altar of him
yes and you're sacrificing your little
boy
on the altar of him
yeah
so I'm asking you do you still like him
or maybe you love him but you're so
enraged because this isn't how it's
supposed to be
[Applause]
I care about his feelings
he doesn't care
it feels like that no I I'm telling you
I'm telling you I hope that he does come
around to care about yours one at one
day
but the fact that he still goes to a
hobby
and has figured out a way for the hobby
to give him a little money so that he
can call it a side job
the fact that he
has not looked at the reality of Your
World he's a non-verbal son that's a
very challenging world it's challenging
because there's nothing more important
to a mom and dad to have that little kid
say I love you and
you haven't had that yet no and it's
devastating
and he hadn't had it he loved me though
I know I I know I know my son watch me
though oh
100 absolutely absolutely but but
there's a reality to it that most people
when they hear non-verbal they don't
understand like
it's it's not the way it's supposed it
hurts hurts
and some people lean way in and some
people run from that
and I'm not saying it's the cause sounds
like you've married a child but all that
to say is this
you care deeply about not hurting him
I would almost be willing to bet you
care about not hurting him because it
makes you look bad
um
no
okay
because I mean I've
there's not let me say this way there's
not a way there's not a way you can save
yourself and him not have to change
and when grown women are married to
little boys
change feels like the end of time
The Whole World's coming down
because they've gotten their way their
whole life
and so what you have to here's the thing
would you ever leave him
I was actually strongly considering it
um our lease is up in June and my my mom
and my sister those are the two that I
actually only two people I can really
talk to about this they both said just
leave just leave and you know you know
we'll do another weekend to help you and
and so I've been strongly considering
leaving when the lease is up and
but I don't know how and I don't know
how to break that to him
because whenever I mentioned these
things he turns it he tries he kind of
turns it around on me like I'm somehow
wrong or I'm
um
you know like I'm overreacting
to something like there's a there's an
additional piece to the driver's license
thing and you're going to and you're
going to hit me I already know I won't
hit you
tell me so
um he actually bought a car before we
before we got together
um he bought it cash from his friend's
mom oh God and then he never registered
it and he couldn't because he didn't
have a driver's license and then fast
forward my car was in the shop I needed
to I needed something to drive so I said
I'll just drive your car if I had to go
register it but I couldn't
um
he couldn't register it because he
didn't have a license so I registered it
under my name and his name and because
I'm the only licensed driver I put
insurance on it because I couldn't
register it otherwise
and so now you know my my car is fixed
and he's driving around this car without
a driver's license using my insurance
and my insurance already told me they
wouldn't cover if there was an accident
and we're in an area where there are a
lot of accidents all the time and he
says well I'm a safe driver and you know
I won't get an accident as I'm not
worried about your driving I'm worried
about the other people I'm worried about
the other people crashing into you and
then my insurance won't cover anything
and
and he says no I'll just pay for it it's
like no you can't even pay the 75 a week
for your half of the of the daycare how
are you going to pay okay hold on hold
on hold on hold on this whole thing is a
mess
it is a mess whole thing's a mess
listen to me listen to me carefully and
what I'm going to say is I would not say
this in an abusive situation but I'm
saying this to you okay so I don't want
everyone who's married in is in a messy
situation to extrapolate there what I'm
about to say to you to their world I'm
just saying this to you
you are getting the world you allow
okay and if here's what I want to
communicate
um I think things are funny that my wife
did not does not think is funny and
I also have a couple of ticks like uh
not like the bugs but like yeah I have
some like vocal tics
and for whatever reason whenever there's
a sound I instantly mimic it
so if there's like a thing in the drawer
and he goes all right I'll just be
across the house and I'll be like and it
just comes out I don't know why I wish
it didn't but it so for the first X
number of years my wife was always
saying stop or what
and then she had a realization she's
just making herself tired and miserable
this is the guy married and I love him
he's hilarious I wish he wouldn't make
that joke at the dinner table but most
of the time he's awesome and I think
it's weird that he makes those noises
but now I think it's endearing because
see what I'm saying so if you're not
gonna leave and you love this guy
stop carrying it around
because you're comparing your life to
him you're frustrated and it's just
adding to the already really difficult
challenge you have of being a working
mother with a autistic son severely
autistic son and a husband that y'all
are still splitting bills with again
very we're not legally married that's
the thing we're not legally married we
live together
so oh my gosh lead with that Marie move
out what are you doing move out because
the lease the lease isn't up until July
cool what's your what's your soul worth
what's your sanity worth
um is it worth a couple of months I
wasn't if I wasn't said dang poor then
all right then that's why I said if I
just hold out until July but I don't
know how to but you know one I wanted to
see if I could get if I could get it
through to him to just grow up he's Hey
listen he's not on the phone so I he
he's on the phone it's like we can't
talk about him is not a good use of our
time okay I can only talk about you
and so too how do I how do I tell that
to him you probably making a whole lot
of crime
zero get that out of out of out of your
world there will be a whole lot of
crying period
there'll be a lot of heartbreak a lot of
the same way he's always reacted he's
going to do that again times more that's
really scary to me okay if you're not
safe you need to leave now
he has never laid his hands on me
so I'm physically safe
I don't believe you
he's never laid his hands on me he's
gotten pretty damn close hadn't he
no he just yells a lot and but the thing
is we only fight like every once every
six months Marie um the last the last
time was about four months ago and what
why
I don't know I don't know what's wrong
with me I don't know how
there's nothing wrong obviously
obviously there is because there's not
so cut and dry when I look at it from
the outside I know you can hear yourself
talking
listen Marie you
have a picture of what you wanted this
thing to look like
yes and I thought when I had two kids it
was gonna look like this and I was gonna
have a partner that was in it with me we
were gonna live here we're gonna go to
Astros games we're gonna do all this
stuff
and it's not
and the sooner you can choose reality
and live out of that reality instead of
this fantasy that you're killing
yourself duct taping together
with tape and string and wire and wood
you're doing whatever you can to keep
this thing patched up
you gotta choose reality and I'm not
even I even think y'all can salvage this
he's gonna have to make some very
significant changes what I often find in
this exact moment
is you have hot yell at him
you have made demands in the middle of
fights you have you've never sat down
over a meal with a typed out piece of
paper and said here's what I need
and if you are choosing to not help me
meet these needs you are choosing for us
to be over I hope you don't make that
choice but that choice is yours to make
and then when the conversation starts oh
you're just
cool old Marie you're right this is new
Marie
and this is from this day forward I
gotta have help with my kid and I know
that I'm asking you to get a new job in
the daytime I am
and I'm asking you to get up in the
morning and help with diapers or
breakfast or whatever you need help with
in dropping off at school and be a part
of his life
and go get your own parental ABA
training so that you know how to deal
with a kid who's severely autistic
because it's hard
and he's probably not going to do it
he has no incentive to right
and I go back to the original thing like
why in the world would he do anything
differently than what he's doing why
would he get a driver's license he has a
car
but right now right this moment you can
get off the phone and call the insurance
company and cancel the insurance
how do I get my name off of the
registration then
it's your car
I know I've thought about that I've told
him that too and then he called me
greedy
and I said but I'm the one who is paying
for all the stuff on this car you don't
even have a license and then he called
me greedy and he also called me greedy
when I asked for
um you know my hat for his half of the
daycare
I he's employed full time I'm played
part-time while I'm in school I can't I
would give you money
why I don't
because that was our agreed that was our
agreement and it had been it had been
going like that until August and then
they called your bluff
well he had been paying and then August
happened and I don't know what happened
in August but oh the the daycare cost
went up and then suddenly he couldn't
afford it it's like yeah because I can
you make twice as much as I do how do
you not afford it
and then the day just goes on
yeah
I'm heartbroken for you Marie because I
know you're trapped I I know you it
feels like you're trapped you're not
trapped it feels like you are and I get
that and I also think you love this guy
you probably don't like him but I think
you love this guy or you love the idea
of him and what y'all could have had
together what y'all might still have
together
but I also hear an exhausted mother of a
special needs kid and an exhausted
mother who's trying to go to school and
to work
and he's tired of also carrying a third
kid that's now got a missile that he's
unlicensed to be driving
hauling around Houston Texas which does
not have a bunch of great drivers in it
no
no if there's um that's where I grew up
there's at least there's like two to
three accidents right outside of our our
neighborhood every day flowers of the
day all of that all of that is a proxy
for one thing
is Maria gonna care about is Marie gonna
care about Marie
the way she's trying to care for
everybody else
and until you get there
you're just gonna walk around frustrated
because nobody's going to change there's
no reason to change you're not gonna
leave you're gonna figure out how to get
a couple more shifts and pay for it
you're gonna end up getting done with
school and making a bunch of money
you're gonna take care of the kids
Nothing's Gonna Change
I know and that's so awful to me that's
why I called yeah I hate
I hinge and I don't that's what I
thought how do I change it just one way
take that actually take the no no I
don't I don't think that's the first
step I think the first step is
doing whatever you can to it's the same
as I do with my kid
just like I said it earlier okay just
like I said earlier
um
here is what I need
I need a partner that wakes up with me
in the morning
and helps with the kid
I need a partner who
um
helps with bedtime
I need a partner who will get trained
and help me out
I need someone who has a plan for are we
going to get married or not
someone who because I want to get
married so that we can create a
long-term safe life together that I
don't know you're not just going to take
off on oh just all in all and all in all
I need someone sometimes I need to leave
and go be with my friends because I'm
working like crazy
all of those things you got to spend
some time with you writing down here's
what I need
and these are different than wants
here's what I need
and then he gets to choose are you in or
you out
you've got to come up with your or what
statement I will never tell somebody to
leave unless they're being abused okay
you've got to come up with your or what
statement and you've got to own the
weight of it Marie I won't take that
from you
if he doesn't do these things or what
what are you gonna do
and that's the cross you have to bear if
you want to stay I'll be here and I'll
talk you through it if you want to go
I'll be here and I'll talk you through
it
but he's got no incentive to change Zero
none
because you're carrying everything
as someone who spent her whole life
being a peacekeeper making sure
everybody else's needs were taken care
of and everybody else was happy and
everybody else liked you
My Hope and prayer for you is at some
point you say I'm worthy of that Same
Love
and it has to start with me
you're worth being wilmbury